cord cutting isn't just umbilical
anymore the televisions popularity as
the go-to entertainment device may be
ending according to a research report
from accenture according to the report
TV was the only product category to see
double-digit u6 decline among viewers of
nearly all ages being rapidly replaced
by anytime anywhere players such as
laptops tablets and mobile phones
viewership for long-form video content
such as movies and television on a TV
screen has declined by thirteen percent
over the past year while sports
viewership on TV screens declined by ten
percent gavin man eccentric broadcast ly
explained TV shows and movies are now
viewing staple on mobile devices thanks
to improve streaming and longer battery
life the second screen viewing
experience is where content creators
broadcasters and programmers will
succeed or fail so we've done a bunch of
stories on this I'm fascinated by this
topic because everyone still wants to
get to television yet you guys are
watching this online right now we know
the future is online but as a as a TV
guy do you think what do you think the
battle the battle front is gonna be at
is it going to be the second screen
thing where the home will always be on
television but you'll still you'll be
doing something else on your iPad the
whole time is there some land I mean I
need the evidence here to be ugly more
anecdotal like I need to see how that
works I mean I it's not like I don't do
it is not like I don't watch a movie and
look at IMDb and revive myself who's in
it so I guess I'm doing it that it uh
but it keeps you keep talking about 14
to 17 year olds who do it I don't know
what they're doing like what what is it
they're doing well they're they're just
not consuming tell they don't immunity
turning on television when they get home
from school the way we may have all
turned on television they me they're
just walking around alright a couple
things here that are that were left out
of that little report that are important
i'm a big sort of defender than in tv's
fighting strikes like it's not gonna
reverse right if not gonna gain coming
back right but my hunch is there's a
plateau and it's still gonna be a lot of
people watching television even though
the future may be here and the
disappointing thing is that the communal
aspect of television yeah it passed as i
hope stays i mean because we know we're
not gonna talk right now
so that's out this is the only time I
Drive all day actually like the idea you
know those were those were countrywide
moments the moat you know then everybody
gather around a watch Seinfeld and and
and let alone the drink every at you're
sitting next to the dresser sit next to
the Drake that's right and everybody
loved the Drake let alone air everybody
that let alone every single episode of
every every single Super Bowl every
single big sporting event so and that
you know at least when it's your tablet
or your I was this weekend i watch an
NBA playoff game on somebody's
smartphone with six guys it was a joke
oh god you know we're all like yeah um
uh so I don't know I I there is still
gonna be a sense of community viewing
and television has a big role in that
although sometimes that just maybe
obviously the television screen and
watching Netflix or Amazon Prime yeah on
it Rick do you think there's something
to be said for not being able to get
everything on demand the second you want
it you know what I mean even though
television is going that way too because
you can get stuff on demand on TV
obviously as well but do you think
there's something to be said for the old
school Oh at eight o'clock friends is
coming on and we're all watching it
together to draw the parable two nite
club comedy and it it had its rarity
factor dug in too deeply by a digital
media world where they can also
videotape you off their phone quietly
from their table while you're breaking a
bit in yeah put it on YouTube killing
any desire to see it in its refined form
later when I some workshop and I don't
need to pay to see the finished one yeah
you know and so a bit it has eaten up
the the rarity factor which you know
exclusivity and rarity bring up the
price of a thing another part of that
piece that I think is is is is important
to note is that the trust factor of
people is still in the content provided
by the known entities yes and that's so
maybe television isn't going to be i'm
watching friends in eight o'clock and
and
and wings at eight-thirty and he won't
work oh I've cheers at nine no no matter
what your is an item i courted 9 30 LOL
wow the NBC 1981 so that's so that's
that's gone but they still want to watch
that that if NBC can still produce
friends and cheers and LA Law notice
when I left out there on the uh uh you
know there's still a market for that it
just won't be at ten o'clock on
thursdays but you know you that that's
still what people want to see and there
are still only going to be if a limited
number of entities that can produce that
kind of quality I think with this tells
you is that the idea of to quote
Springsteen 15 years ago or business 57
Chan more than that 20 years ago 57
channels and nothing on now 357 channels
and nothing on we probably cannot
sustain that many channels we got did
these stats have to mean that some
channels are just gonna go away I would
think yeah bring us some pay to have to
pay all that money originally cable the
whole point of cable was no commercials
it's all commercials now it's all coming
with numbers commercial except I'll
Turner Classic Movies there every movie
as it was meant to be seen uncut
commercial Turner Classic the good stuff
it's almost as if someone here works for
its better classic movies I'm actually a
big fan of tournament anyway what do you
guys think are you cutting the cord are
you okay with staring at everything on
your small device let us know in the
comments right down below